لو كنت امظفه في احدى الدوائر الفيدراليه
الامريكيه لم تمكنت من تحميل تطبيق تيك
توك على هاتفي الخاص
صفحه لك او تيك توك لن تكون متاحه لاعضاء
مجلس النواب والموظفين الحكوميين في كل
الدوائر الامريكيه بعد ان تم تصنيف
التطبيق بانه ينطوي على مخاطر عاليه على
الامن القومي الامريكي بسبب افتقاله
للشفافيه في كيفيه حمايه بيانات العملاء
الامريكيين
الاخيره واليوم بدانا نرى الخطوات الاولى
من الولايات المتحده لحظر موظف الحكومه
الامريكيه والحكومه الفيدراليه من استخدام
تيك توك وبالتالي منع البكيني من الولوج
الى شبكه الاتصالات الامريكيه وهواتف
الامريكيين واستخدام بياناتهم ومعرفه
تفاصيل حياته
الكونجرس اقر مشروع قانون للانفاق بقيمه
التريليون و 700 مليار دولار يتضمن وحضرتك
من الاجهزه الحكوميه وسيسر الحظر بمجرد
توقيع بيضا على التشريعي ليصبح قانونا
حظر
خطوه انتظرناها سيد الرئيس
تعمل
ملكه لمنصه تيك توك
لو لو واحد عنده فيديو وموجود على التلفون
بتاعه لسه ما حمل ما وصل الى تك تك يحصل
على نسخه عليه قبل حتى ما يحملوا على تيك
تاك يعني للدرجه هذه فكون انك تزيل نهائيا
من من الهاتف تبعك هو هذا الحل
الان متاخره العمليه
بدات بعض الولايات ايضا حضرتك وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من الاجهزه الحكوميه
حتى الان حضرت الساعه 10:00 ولايه امريكيه
تيك توك جزئيا واخر المنضمين الى ركب
المقاطعين ولايه كانساس التي وقعت حاكمتها
امرا تنفيذيا يحضر تطبيق وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي على الاجهزه التي تصدرها الدوله
في السلطه التنفيذيه سليمان العربيه
واشنطن